about four or five years ago uh china
published something called china 2025. i
mean this was kind of a blueprint
for an industrial policy where they were
going to capture global leadership in 15
major technologies what are your
thoughts about that and is that a threat
to us
um i i think we want to do the same in a
sense you you want to compete and be the
best that you can and the question is um
is that
competition by its nature
turns into a warlike behavior and then
what are the rules of the games
about taking each other's
intellectual property how does that work
how do how do we know that that's being
used for safety um i was surprised that
people were so surprised um about that
um yes so we should assume um that there
are that both countries are going to
want to develop the best technologies
and take the leadership because also
technology is both uh economic and
military when ever wins the technology
wars wins the economic and the military
wars so there's a heck of a lot of
incentive to do that right and both will
develop and both can be threatening or
both can be uplifting to each other
depending how it's handled